un pèlerinage masqué du jamais vu en 126
ans mais une obligation pour les
mourides cette année car malgré
l'épidémie de coronavirus pas question
de manquer cet événement religieux situé
à l'uqtr ramona les fans d'amy smart
on a cassé le jeu se joue de nous
adonner
les nigérians n'ont pas put mais les
moulins
respecté ni et les barrières
en tout 1 million et demi de personnes
se sont rendues à touba entre ce lundi
soir et mardi soir la population de la
ville a triplé en 24 heures de nombreux
disciples ayant fait le déplacement
depuis des pays voisins
alors pour tenter d'éviter la
propagation du coït 19 les autorités
sénégalaises ont mis les bouchées
doubles 500 millions de masques ont été
distribués aux fidèles et 5000 employés
du ministère de la santé ont été
déployés pour veiller au respect des
règles sanitaires
en revanche à deux cérémonies
officielles cette année les conférences
ont lieu sur internet et pour se
recueillir dans la grande mosquée de
touba
il a fallu faire la queue dans une file
d'attenté unique
l'efficacité de ces mesures barrière
sera scruté à la loupe dans les semaines
qui viennent
en effet un autre événement religieux
le gamou qui rassemble la confrérie des
tidianes cette fois doit avoir lieu à la
fin du mois à tivaouane à 90 km de dakar
la capitale
pour l'instant aucune confirmation n'a
été annoncée pour l'heure le pays
déplore 15000 contamination pour un peu
plus de 300 morts depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire